sekiro is an excellent game then it only has a
wonderful story but also a unique approach to its
storytelling that hasn't been seen in the soul
series before it's a game that was an enjoyable
experience throughout every moment i played and i
cannot recommend it enough as always welcome back
to another story review the series where i not
only discuss the game's story but also critique
it along the way today's episode is going to be on
sekiro with many more souls games to come in the
near future if you do want to see some more souls
content you can also watch my bloodborne video
that i published about a month ago but with that
out of the way let's get started so to no one's
surprise sakura like other souls game starts with
a cut scene that sets the background for the story
sekiro takes place in japan during the sengoku
era we also learned that there was a rebellion
that was started which ultimately led to a victory
thanks to a soldier named Isshin Ashina who was
responsible for slaying the opposing faction's
leader General Tamura after the battle of shinobi
by the name of owl discovers a child sitting
around dozens of bodies and decides to welcome the
child into his home he then trains this young boy
in the way of the sword as well as the iron code
which is that the father's word is absolute and
the master's word being second in priority through
years of training and hardship this child would
become a full-fledged shinobi and our protagonist
known as wolf but something went wrong both owl
and his master are gone so with no purpose in his
life he now just sits at the bottom of a well
waiting for a purpose or death whatever comes
first however one day he receives a note that
leads him to the moonlight tower and when wolf
arrives at said tower he finds lord kuro who is
not only the divine heir but also his master kuro
needs some assistance he wants to escape ashina
as the never ending war that has plagued japan is
slowly making its way back to ashina castle and
kurl wants to leave and run away from what he
calls the faded bloodline the two take a secret
passage but are caught by Genichiro Ashina the
adopted grandson of Isshin Ashina Genichiro wants
kuro it's unclear why but he needs him for his
plan and won't let us escape so we fight and being
the skilled shinobi that we are we have no problem
getting absolutely destroyed by him Genichiro cuts
off wolf's arm who then collapsed from blood loss
while Genichiro takes kuro away somehow though
wolf was able to survive thanks to an old man
named the sculptor who was not only able to nurse
him back to health but also give him a prosthetic
wooden arm to replace our recently cut off one
from the sculptor we learned one thing kinichiro
plans to use kuro's bloodline for something and we
need to get him back thus setting the game's plot
in motion so already this is a fantastic start and
this intro highlights many unique design decisions
within sekiro firstly it took six games what we
now finally have a named and voice protagonist
sekiro still retains that soul's formula of giving
the player a title like Ashen One or Hunter as
in this game were referred to as the shinobi of
the divine heir but most characters will still call
him wolf furthermore it's evident right from the
beginning that this game has a very unique style
to its storytelling sekiro is a very cutscene
and dialogue-driven game sekiro has a lot of
cutscenes and conversations especially in the very
beginning and many of the game's objectives can be
completed without talking to npcs as opposed
to other games where npcs were just optional
the story is also quite linear and this ties into
the npcs as well as many characters will repeat
quest objectives about four to five times then a
couple minutes to make sure the player knows what
they're doing and will also have to report back
to these npcs once the objectives are completed
the souls games also love to draw inspiration
from specific media and bloodborne took this
a step further by making hp lovecraft and his
lovecraftian stories be the inspiration for the
game's plot and while sekiro does do this as well
instead of fully embracing the fictional elements
of h.p lovecraft like with bloodborne sekiro goes
in the opposite direction and instead focuses on
non-fiction storytelling by using history culture
and religion all of these decisions are very bold
especially coming from a game series that likes to
stick to what it knows best this further added to
the attraction of the game as this was something
the soul series has never done before however one
of these decisions being the history and culture
surrounding the game will become an issue to
explain why we need to recap that intro again with
the proper context as I said this game takes place
in the sengoku era of japan which was a real time
period in japan's history it was an over 100 year
conflict that started because the shogunate at
the time was losing influence this then caused
many of the local lords to vie for power and
attempt to dismantle all the other lords and even
overtake the shogunate the main purpose was to
eventually unify all of japan under one rule and
after the final battle called the siege of osaka
japan was eventually unified under the rule of
tokugawa iyasu relating this back to sekura that's
why the first line in the game japan was consumed
by a perpetual conflict makes sense as that
matches with the current time period the sengoku
era more transpires then it also brings context to
what's going on in the game japan is still under
siege and judging from the use of guns and the
lore of ashina it seems that we're entering the
final years of the conflict that means ashina
castle is either one of or the only place left
now fully unified under japan the question though
is how is this possible well one of these reasons
is integral to the main plot which is immortality
but we'll circle back to that later as the other
reason was Isshin Ashina is already incredibly
strong because of its generals but Isshin was on a
whole other level considering the fact that Isshin
is probably in his 70s or 80s in a profession with
a very low survival rate the fact that he is
alive at all is quite terrifying especially when
you consider that because wolf was a child
during this battle, Isshin has to be around
50 years old and was able to single-handedly take
down the enemy factions general so obviously it's
quite clear that sekiro decided to utilize a very
important time period in japan's history as the
backdrop for its story and while i do like this
approach there is an issue because of the history
of this game it can be very hard to understand
what it's trying to say sekiro is a japanese game
made by a japanese developer and since the game
contains material they're familiar with they're
free to go as in depth as possible to create an
accurate story and while that's great for the
japanese audience this can confuse and damper a
bit of the experience for everyone else however
while i did call this an issue it's really hard
to complain about this decision as it's not really
something you can say is inherently bad more just
unfortunate playing sekiro and trying to connect
this game to japan's history is like a japanese
audience playing assassin's creed 3 and connecting
that game to america's history the games are fine
on their own but the problem of course is when one
group tries to play the other for an example
we can take the cherry blossom trees in japan
the ones with the pink petals this tree represents
new beginnings good fortune and revival which is
why these pink petals appear when we revive
in game without looking into this information
you could just assume that they were just visual
effects without any real meaning but within their
culture there's a reason for this just like i said
before on its own it's not a big deal but it can
be quite troublesome when you have to juggle
the meaning of the cherry blossom trees along
with all the other references like why the devs
chose to have giant snakes and dragons be these
large creatures as opposed to any other animal
why this game has a fascination with centipedes
and even just the basic ideas of buddhism to
understand every single detail and reference
in sekiro you will need to have lots of extensive
knowledge outside of the game but as someone who
doesn't i can say with certainty that the only
real info you need to learn is the history i
summarized regarding the sengoku period everything
else is nice and definitely really interesting
to look into if you're passionate about the
history of japan and how it ties into sekiro
but i don't think it's necessary to understand
the story this game is really trying to tell
as we discussed earlier our objective is to rescue
the divine heir from Genichiro the problem is that
he's all the way at the top of ashina castle and
while the journey to get kuro was very engaging
thanks to the combat for the purposes of this
video it does get a little boring sekiro like
many games has certain parts where the gameplay is
at the forefront this because the game is trying
to familiarize us with stealth grapple posture
and deflect mechanics that make up the core combat
so because of this the story takes a backseat
for a bit so we can understand these mechanics
it's not an issue and it's something i never
complain about it just makes it discussing the
story of the game a bit difficult when the next
five to six hours we don't make a whole lot of
progress so before we get to the castle let's
take a step back and talk about the game itself
sekiro is a very gorgeous game and the level
design and exploration is quite linear compared to
other souls games as while some areas do connect
to one another it's not as intricate as the souls
trilogy with its shortcuts and branching pathways
however i still firmly believe the intention of
this game was to create a different take on the
gameplay and storytelling so I don't mind its
linearity and even if that wasn't the intended
purpose a game being linear doesn't make it bad
insecure just goes to show that a souls game can
be very linear and still provide an enjoyable
experience it's during this exploration although
we are introduced to our base of operations as
well as some npcs that we'll be meeting quite
a bit the dilapidated temple is definitely one
of my favorite locations because i love the area's
seclusion and also how it fits into the world very
seamlessly the past souls games did this very
well with the firelink shrine from dark souls1
being a highlight but recently the series has
started delving into this idea that the base of
operation should be separate from the main content
like the hunter's dream or the roundtable hold in
sekiro though instead of teleporting for the base
of operations to a spot on the map you could just
simply walk out the front gate and start exploring
it's a small detail but i really enjoyed that
about the dilapidated temple within the temple
are three npcs that we'll get to know throughout
the game who are the sculptor the man who saved us
and is responsible for creating and upgrading our
prosthetic tool emma who's a doctor that serves
under lord isshin and will also upgrade our gourd
and hanbe who is a target dummy who can't die
due to some form of immortality minus the three
of the dilapidated temple and some of the others
that are more related to the story the game also
has some optional npcs we can talk to but it's
definitely not one of sakura's strong suits
a lot of the optional npcs seem to only be placed
in the world for one specific reason like this one
dying soldier who warns us of the enemy ahead
or this monk who found his way into the halls
of illusion and has no plans of leaving that's
literally their entire character probably the
only interesting npc in this game is jinzaemon
this random warrior that patrols the outskirts
of ashina who is entranced by some music that he
can only hear we end up following him throughout
the game until we find him gravely injured near
this apparition called lady orin she asked us
about this lord sakuza and if we've seen him
before and seeing as we have no clue who that is
we tell her no but she gets angry and claims that
we're lying to her after defeating orin it seems
like her mind has gained some sort of clarity as
she seems happy to die she can now be with lord
sakuza implying that this sakuza along with her
are both dead but the reason she's still here is
because her spirit couldn't pass on so we kind of
help her continue into the afterlife once we talk
with jinzaemon again he gives us a jizo statue
and from this dialogue in the item description
it seems to imply that he was related to orin
and sakuza and was possibly the couple's son
apparently this may also be related to a popular
japanese ghost story which once again further adds
to the beauty of this questline jin zaiman is one
of the few npcs in this game with an actual quest
line and is by far the best at it another npc that
i definitely took a liking to was kotaro but not
because of a quest line but more just because he's
a really sweet kid and it's kind of hard to hate
him but while jinzaemon quest was great it was a
little bittersweet as it makes me wish that they
could apply this same effort to other characters
and not have this overabundance of npcs and
merchants that don't really say anything but one
line getting back to the story while progressing
through the ashina outskirts you may stumble
upon these ghost figures which are actually just
remnants of lord kuro this remnant is specifically
important as it's a conversation between
genichiro and kuro who talks about the inner
ministry and how they were able to drive them back
once but their army is too powerful this is why
genichiro wants kuro because he knows that ashina
can be defended by normal means but what does he
mean by this well lord koro is part of a divine
lineage that is related to the divine dragon
and this lineage gives kuro the power of the
dragon's heritage which is immortality this is why
genichiro wants kuro he wants to gain the power
of the dragon's heritage through lord kuro that
he can be immortal and prevent ashina from being
taken over this not only gives us a hint of the
events to come as it briefly mentions the interior
ministry but also lets us learn a bit more about
genichiro we'll end up seeing more of him later
but genichiro might be my favorite character in
this whole game as his backstory and motivation
fit so well together according to some item
descriptions related to genichiro we discover that
he was taken in by ashina when his mother died so
he's extremely grateful for the people that live
here so much so that he sees them as his extended
family so when the country of his people is under
attack he'll do anything he can to save them even
if it means using heretical arts the description
is both cryptic and informative as it shows that
he's willing to go as far as possible to defend
ashuna but we don't know what those heretical arts
are this is also probably a good time to mention
the item descriptions as just like previous games
some of sekiro's lore is discovered via item
descriptions main bosses will drop memories which
when consumed for attack power turn into remnants
the remnants are where the heart of the stories
are and while for some they don't provide too much
information for most of the bosses it's definitely
enough to get an idea of who they were thanks to
its accessible story and access to the remnants
you can get a large amount of the story just from
these two sources and it continues to reinforce
that this difference in storytelling was a bold
but fantastic choice right next to the remnant
of genichiro and kuro is a large battlefield
which also happens to be the arena for the first
boss kiyobu masataka oniwa i never mentioned this
before but sekiro can be played in japanese with
english subtitles this is similar to ghost of
tsushima which i believe also has the same feature
in the rare case that a game will offer me this
option i usually take the original language as i
feel it's authentic as i normally have subtitles
on anyway but if there was ever a reason to play
this game in english it's this intro
my name is gyoubu masataka oniwa
as i breathe you will not pass the castle gate
it is so over the top and absurd that i couldn't
help but laugh and it kind of speaks to gyoubu's
character gyoubu was a leader of a group of
bandits but when they came face to face with
isshin they were easily defeated however during
their fight isha noticed his determination and
skill so he would decide to take him in as an
ashina warrior gyoubu really values strength over
everything and that's why he has this aggressive
demeanor when he attacks us because he knows
he's powerful and he can portray that to us
interestingly enough the spear that he uses
also seems to be the same spirit that general
tamura used during his battle with ishin which is
quite poetic and that also brings up a good point
and it's something i really appreciate about
this game and it's how wonderful and detailed
the presentation is a good example is the minor
details that occur throughout the game such as
tomorrow's spear which is used by giobu and then
will eventually be used by ishin later in the game
furthermore when we challenge genichiro again
we're able to see wolf's growth as a shinobi as
he pulls out the sword with ease whereas in the
intro we can see him fumbling with the hilt there
are also the similar circumstances between the
sculptor and wolf who were both fighters that had
their arms removed the sculptor had his removed
by isshin whereas wolf had his removed by genichiro
we have two unrelated people who became a team
cutting off the limbs of two unrelated people
who became a team interesting this even extends to
the cutscenes before the fights especially the one
with genichiro again which takes place in this
beautiful land of flowers and the camera angle
specifically positions him to the side so the full
length of his sword along with the moon is shown
in the scene speaking of genichiro we can now talk
about his boss fight after defeating gyoubu and the
blazing bull you're presented with this tower
along with numerous other buildings attached to
it this is the heart of ashina castle and gonichu
always at the top assuming you make it to the top
you'll be greeted by emma kuro and genichiro he's
still trying to get kuro's powers but he won't
budge that's when we step in and attempt to save
him i like the stakes of this fight as not only
is it a rematch between wolf and genichiro it's a
rematch between him and us we finally get to get
payback for him cutting off our arm but ganichibro
came prepared he's still a competent fighter and
could definitely be the first wall players will
run into but just when you think you've finally
beaten him genichiro proves that he's willing to
do whatever it takes to save ashina and fights
using the way of tomoe which means he's going
to throw lightning at us thankfully we learned a
lightning reversal just before this fight and
can send it back to him but i'd be lying if
i told you i wasn't shocked when this happened
one thing i noticed as well was the black marks
on his body you could just play these off as
wounds but i think these are from the lightning
powers of his as maybe it's trying to convey that
genichiro harmed himself when attempting to control
lightning for the first time regardless it's a
nice detail but what's even better is the name
the way of tomoe, tomoe is an unknown character at
this point in time and we'll talk about her a bit
later towards the end but i really love how they
connected her in genichiro as tomoe was his master
and he learned the lightning attacks from her
which is interesting as the only other people able
to conjure lightning in this game are the okami
women at the fountainhead palace plus they can
also do a move called the floating passage which
is a skill that we can learn which is also the
same move that genichiro does to us meaning he was
trained by tomoe who's an okami woman as i said it
doesn't mean much now but once we learn a bit more
about them you'll come to appreciate the parallels
between them and how well this was conveyed
to us it's similar to how bloodborne had to
rely on context clues in the environment to convey
certain parts of the story such as the backstory
of the one reborn being connected to yahar ghoul
and i really love how this was integrated again
eventually though we will defeat genichiro and
rescue kuro but he's still not done for now he
leaves but not only will we see him again later
the way of tomoe wasn't even close to his full
arsenal as that resurrection is a part of his next
surprise the rejuvenating waters i think it's been
long enough so let's talk about the elephant in
the room that being this game's obsession with
immortality both genichiro and kuro are immortal but
there are two others that we know about that being
hanbe and wolf who are also immortal resurrecting
isn't just a gameplay mechanic it's a genuine part
of the story their various different forms of
immortality or more accurately for some of them
body altering methods within sakura the first
is the dragon's heritage which is created with
someone of divine blood like lord koro he also
has the power to give people immortality to what's
called the immortal oath that's why we're able to
live because kuro gave wolf his blood during the
hirata estate attack something i'll mention later
this is the purest form of immortality because it
comes from the divine dragon and is very easy to
acquire but it comes at a price if someone has
the dragon's heritage their blood stagnates says
they can never die however should someone with the
dragon's heritage die enough times then that blood
overflows and creates a disease called dragon rot
remember you can still die with the dragon's
heritage inside you but you can't fully die
you just resurrect soon after when we die our
blood stagnates and if we keep dying then the
disease will spread this dragon rot disease has a
chance of affecting the npcs throughout the game
although to be honest this never really became
an issue for me as most of the people who were
affected were merchants and yes while it does
have the chance of completely halting npc quest
lines i've never had this happen but maybe
i just got lucky our next immortality has to
do with the divine child of rejuvenation she
becomes relevant in the story after the fight
with genichiro but she has what we can call false
dragon's heritage that's because the monks at the
senpou temple became enthralled by the concept of
immortality so much so that they devoted every
waking minute to try and perfect it they even
attempted to use children in their experiments
to see if they could create their version of
the dragon's heritage kotaro was the caretaker
for these kids and is sad because all the kids
have left him the reason they left though is
because they died if these statues and pinwheels
are meant to symbolize each child then a lot of
them have passed away from this in fact we can
meet a parent of the kids here at the temple
the armored warrior is a european soldier who came
to japan because of these rejuvenating waters and
the promise of fixing this illness but that ended
up not working across the temple are these red and
white pinwheels that are for the children who
died but there's one pure white pinwheel that
represents the only survivor of the experiments
who is the divine child of rejuvenation
as i said she's the only one to have survived and
even though she's happy to be alive she detests
the monks that did this to her and her friends the
child however is in the inner sanctum an area that
is only accessed once we beat the folding screen
monkeys in the halls of illusion which according
to some item descriptions is a place that exists
between the planes of life and death implying
that this is a spiritual plane that can only be
accessed by a select few the only ones able to
access this place are kotaro this random monk
and us it's possible though that if someone is
infested they may not be allowed to enter and by
infested i mean the centipedes we see everywhere
the monks of the sempo temple and even some other
notable enemies like the guardian ape and the
corrupted monk are seen covered in centipedes
and the centipedes seem to make them immortal
we don't know why but they just do for some
reason but there's a key distinction between this
and kuros power whereas kuro's power allows
one to resurrect the centipede prevents the
host from dying at all they can never resurrect
because they're never going to die in the first
place there are two books we can find in the
game called the holy chapter infested and the
holy chapter dragon's return that seemed to infer
that the high priest of senpou temple was blessed
by the centipede and that because it had become
one with him he was able to walk the path of
immortality but he wanted to find out why however
it seems like he was never able to find an answer
what we can assume though is that the centipede
possibly came from the rejuvenating waters which
could explain their ability to make their host
immortal as the guardian ape is located near
the lotus of the palace a flower that according to
its description is near the palace waters and the
corrupted monk is guarding the palace itself which
is obviously surrounded by its water which then
leads us to our final method of immortality which
is the rejuvenating waters however earlier i said
body altering method not necessarily immortality
because the rejuvenating waters don't seem to
make people immortal the rejuvenating waters came
from the divine dragon when it entered the land of
japan ages ago it then expelled this water across
the land the water originally started in a place
called the fountainhead palace but then would
make it eventually to mibu village currently the
theory i have is that the distance of the water
relative to the source is important as i think
the farther it travels the fewer side effects
occur as within the fountainhead palace we can
find these carp-like nobles who patrol the area
whereas in meebu village they're still semi-human
we do know that the water started at fountainhead
palace and did make its way to mibu village but
it seems like the villagers didn't know of its
origin and its side effects as from what we can
gather the town mayor treated the villagers to
tons of sake one night but when you drink sake
you obviously get really thirsty and since they
ran out they had to resort to drinking water from
the stream but then the side effects kicked in
turning them into these semi-zombie type humans
however all the inhabitants of both locations can
die when we kill them so it doesn't seem to make
them immortal maybe just prolong their life or
grant them some resistances the only character
who doesn't fit into this equation is genichiro
as he clearly resurrects wolf even says it himself
confirming that we did kill ganichiro at this
point but the waters brought him back to life so
how is this possible rejuvenating sediment that's
what we call a particularly concentrated part
of the rejuvenating waters i'm sure you saw it
for yourself the rejuvenating sediment grants
great resilience in one's flesh one becomes able
to withstand blows that would be fatal to anyone
else so it seems that genichiro consumed
the rejuvenating sediment instead of the
rejuvenating waters which is why he reacted to
it differently than those at mibu village so
as a recap we have the purest form of immortality
that being the dragon's heritage within kuro the
unexpected immortality of the centipedes the child
of rejuvenation who was created as a way for the
sempo temple to make a false dragon's heritage
and then the rejuvenating waters and sediment
that seemed to grant resistances and possibly a
prolonged life when ingested so the next question
you might be asking is why is this important well
once again it all leads back to lord kuro
being the divine heir with the dragon's heritage
wants to sever his ties to his immortality has
he seen the effects it has on people and does not
wish for this power to be used by anyone remember
when the story used to be about rescuing a child
well now it's about immortality this is very
similar to bloodborne storytelling where it hides
the true story until the halfway point of the game
i think bloodborne did this much better as that
was intended to be a major plot twist but i
can't deny that sakura has succeeded quite well in
doing the same as i said earlier sakura's story is
very simple save lord kuro then sever his ties of
immortality but when you jump down the rabbit hole
of sakura you realize just how deep it truly goes
and that without a doubt definitely deserves some
recognition so we have our new goal but where do
we start we'll do some dialogue with both kuro and
emma we discover what items we specifically need
these items also tie into the game's endings which
i really liked as for once i knew what the items
were why they were important and what ending they
are required for which made me even more invested
in the story while some of these items are only
for specific endings each one of them requires
two necessary items that being the mortal blade
and the divine dragon tears the mortal blade can
be given to us by the child of rejuvenation who
claims that everyone who's picked up this weapon
has died which is not an issue because we can't
die the mortal blade is important as the actual
blade itself can kill those who cannot die meaning
we can sever kuro's immortality however if you're
puzzled by that description then you and emma have
caught on to kuros's plan wolf is extremely loyal
to kuro and without him he would have no purpose
so if he were to tell wolf to sever his ties by
killing him he probably wouldn't go through with
it so emma and wolf devise a plan and try to
prevent this from happening however this isn't
good news either emma talks with the sculptor and
also finds some notes written by tomoe the girl
we talked about earlier and discovers that to
sever the ties of immortality while keeping the
master alive the one who has the blood must die
so now we're at a crossroads we either sever the
ties of immortality by killing kuro obviously not
a good choice or we kill ourselves and allow kuro
to live also not a good choice but there is a
third option through some discussion with the
divine child of rejuvenation we discovered that
it's possible to sever the ties of immortality by
sending the divine dragon back to where it came
from allowing both kuro and wolf to live while
also forcing the dragon to return home this
also ties into the second item we need which
is the divine dragon tears which are just simply
tears from the divine dragon which is necessary
for the ritual meaning we somehow have to get to
this divine realm so those are our three options
each one requires specific items for the ritual
to work properly so it's on the player to find
these items then do the ending they want i know
it sounds like we skipped really far ahead in the
story but now that we've hit the halfway point the
game really focuses on the severance ritual that
we must perform but it's not the entire focus i
said earlier that the remnant of genichiro and
kuro was a foreshadowing of the events to come
and it's during these next few hours when wolf
scavenges the land for the required items that
this will occur after returning to ashina with
the shelter stone and one of the items we need
for the ritual we'll notice that something's wrong
all the fast travel points are gone and by
making our way back to ashino we discover
that these central forces have started their
assault the central forces are the samurai
dressed in red with the purple soldiers being
the most elite group called the interior ministry
remember sakura takes place at the end of the
sengoku era so it can be assumed that these
central forces are trying to take over ashina
that they may unify japan under their banner
and if that wasn't bad enough an old relative
makes his appearance what are you plotting al
plotting i would do no such thing owl has returned
and he's here for one reason kuro see owl's been
plotting something for years and has been using
wolf this entire time i will just like genichiro
wants the blood of kuro owl wants to be immortal
in order for him to do this he'll need a foolproof
plan firstly he needs someone who can get close to
him that someone would be wolf how was he certain
that wolf was going to follow him well he saved
him from when he was young and became his father
figure over the years he also instilled the iron
code within wolf something that he wanted him to
live by just in case he needed to use it as i said
before the iron code states that the father's word
is absolute with the masters being second so with
that in mind it makes sense why owl wants wolf to
follow the rules of the code so that owl can enact
his plan the question that remains is where has
owl been well very early in the game you'll be
given a bell charm by an old lady by taking this
to the buddha statue at the temple you can relive
a memory from the hirata estate there's also
another bell charm that you can find that belongs
to owl which will also take us to the hirata
estate the hirata estate memory was three years
in the past and it allows us to see the events of
a very important time in sekiro's story except an
issue will arise from both the bells as it's that
both of them showcase the events of the hirata
estate but either have wrong information or it's
in the wrong order for example the end boss of the
first memory is a lady butterfly who we kill but
in the second memory it's owl who we also kill the
second one is clearly wrong as if we killed owl in
the past he wouldn't be here in the present so to
do this properly we're gonna have to jump between
both memories to get the real truth so three
years ago wolf was sent out on some mission
it's unclear by who but we can assume it was owl
when wolf returns he finds the estate in flames
apparently some bandits took it upon themselves
to burn the estate down kill the villagers and
robbed the place clean the reason this attack
worked so well is because many of the estate's
guards were out fighting the wars happening near
ashino the timing of this attack seems too perfect
and some of the villagers think so as well
i wouldn't go that far but he's definitely
correct though that the timing was way too perfect
wolf's main goal as the shinobi of the divine
heir is to find kuro and make sure he's safe
on the way there though he will encounter owl who
seems to be gravely wounded and will pass away
due to his injuries we continue on and find lord
kuro except lady butterfly stops us from leaving
this encounter is interesting as lady butterfly
was wolf's mentor so why is she attacking us my
growing theory is that she's either working with
owl or at the very least betraying ashina before
her boss fight we see this old lady trembling
in fear who happens to be the same old lady
who gives us the bell further down the hallway
is her son inosuke who we can also find in the
present and apparently was injured and rendered
blind by lady butterfly i can't imagine inosuke
was betraying the ashina meaning him and lady
butterfly should have been allies so this leads me
to believe that she was betraying the ashina along
with owl now whether or not they were working
together or just had a common goal is never stated
but i also believe there's an answer to this
after defeating lady butterfly wolf gets stabbed
in the back there is no doubt in my mind that this
was owl which means that not only was he faking
his injuries it's possible he was injured by lady
butterfly and upon discovering that we are here at
the estate he gives us the key to the fort where
kuro is hiding with the hope that will fight her
if we win then he gets to stab us if we lose we'll
have to fight her again but given how much damage
we did to her assuming you actually did damage to
her then owl would have an easier time putting her
down he basically wants us to fight her and then
third party the winner so the divine heir can be
his from this information we can also assume that
he sent us away on a mission so that the divine
heir was unguarded as remember the timing was
almost too perfect after getting stabbed kuro sees
wolf dying and recognizes the bravery he possesses
and gives him his blood this moment is why wolf
can resurrect but that was just one memory the
other memory will tell the real story we learned
from owl's bell charm that the interior ministry
was a part of the attack as well the first memory
will also provide you with a hint to the real
story as we can fight an interior ministry soldier
in that memory except there's only one furthermore
we learn from an eavesdrop conversation between
juzou and a soldier from the ministry that owl was
behind the attack that's why everything worked so
well owl being a shinobi of the ashina would know
the troop movements and knew when to strike as
for why owl joined forces with the ministry it's
because i believe they had aligned goals owl
wanted the divine heir and the interior ministry
wanted to defeat the ashina clan and a huge blow
to their forces would be the hirata estate neither
cared about the other's goals but the two realized
that by attacking the estate together they could
both get what they wanted so they became allies
so now we have to ask how do the bells work
so this involves some magical elements as it seems
that wolf is physically in these memories as not
only does he keep his prosthetic after talking
with one of the ashina shinobi he comments on theattack
there is many times throughout the game that this night gets brought
up but wolf seems to have no memory of this moment
this to me means that wolf is physically in the
memory now maybe in real life he's just getting
images of the memory as we can see him kneeling
before the statue but because this is a video
game we're given control and able to play through
it so it's not entirely clear but what is more
important though is who the bells belong to that
being inosuke's mother and owl the memories are
sort of a point of view of the holder that's why
we don't see the interior ministry in the first
memory as to the old lady's knowledge it was just
the bandits who raided the estate as the ministry
used the bandits to mask their own attacks that
the blame was put on the bandits and not them
owl's bell will obviously have more of the real
story since he was present during the attack but
we still have some more questions to answer
why do we fight owl at the end of the second
memory and what happens after this event well
as for the first question we seem to get the
information from the sculptor according to what
he said it seems that the buddha statue was able
to awaken old memories along with the emotions
and memories the person ringing the bell had
to me the reason we fight owl is so that wolf can
come to terms with his father's betrayal not just
at the estate but later when we get back to the
present as this charm is only found afterwards
buddha is allowing him to let out his emotions
to the only way the two know how it's not a
definitive answer but that's what i've interpreted
from this as for our final question well we know
the answer already the aftermath of the memory is
the intro it seems that while the plan worked owl
was unsuccessful in taking kuro maybe due to the
temple caving in or maybe because kuro managed to
escape either way owl was unable to find him but
seeing as wolf is now the only one alive thanks to
being resurrected from the dragon's heritage and
is now next to the corpse of lady butterfly he was
framed for the attack and thrown in jail this of
course relates to the first conversation we hearin the intro
wolf was tossed away and seeing as he had lost
his purpose along with his weapon they didn't
bother restraining him as it was unnecessary
so basically owl with the assistance of the
interior ministry attacked the hirata estate
using the bandits as cover to mask the truth
of the invasion so that the ministry can get
a staggering blow into ashina forces and owl
can take the divine heir however things went wrong
and owl couldn't take him but he wasn't going to
give up that easily owl then appears three years
later in front of kuro who just outright
tells him that he wants his divine blood
wolf then arrives and owl decides to enact the
plan he attempts to persuade wolf in joining
him by using the iron code and reminding him that
he has to obey his father's word should he agree
this will lead to the first ending in the game
but we'll save that for later as the true choice
is to betray the code remember how i said the
presentations of these fights were breathtaking
i can't tell you how hyped this made me
i was already hooked by the game to begin
with but this one scene had me completely
invested in the fight owl isn't my favorite
boss as that one is specifically held for
someone towards the end but he's definitely
a close second the souls games have always tried
to add variety in their boss encounters sometimes
they have these large slow moves as opposed to
fast consistent swings but other times they have
unique gimmicks the issue with sekiro is that
it's hard to pull this off when the combat is
based around one weapon and one style of play but
it seems that from software wanted to try this
with owl and i think they succeeded throughout the
game we've been using our prosthetic to assist us
in fights it's incredibly powerful and sometimes
too powerful with the introduction of owl we are
now on the receiving end of that treatment as he
throws these balls that prevent us from healing
chucks dozens of shurikens at us and even begs
for mercy at one point just to throw a smoke bomb
at our feet he's a prick and doesn't play fair
at all but given that we've been doing the same
the whole game it's a humbling experience to be on
the receiving end of it plus we're not on an even
playing field as we have two skilled shinobi with
an arsenal of tricks up their sleeve which creates
one of the best fights in this game and the second
encounter with owl makes this all the better as
the hirata estate is a great level i like the idea
of putting together the story through the context
clues in conversation as it retains that soul's
formula of a cryptic story that the player is
forced to figure out my only gripe with this level
is that this integral piece of story is completely
optional the old lady is an optional npc so you
may never find her bell charm thankfully owls is
an item the player can't miss so they'll at least
get one part of the harada estate but the story of
this level is confusing without both bells just
like the story i don't mind the player being
forced to explore and uncover everything on their
own i just feel that something as important as the
estate probably shouldn't have been optional after
we kill owl we can talk to kuro and continue our
duties this is around the time where we discover
the location of the fountainhead palace as well
as kuros plan to kill himself in order to sever
his mortality but we've already talked about that
earlier the only reason i didn't wait until
now to explain it as it would have just been
more confusing so it's around this point in the
game where we go to the fountainhead palace and
attempt to find the divine dragon and the ever
blossom tree or if we want to take a break from
that we can also gather the items for the other
endings but before we go on that journey we can
eavesdrop on isshin and learn that not only will
genichiro return in the future but he plans to
bring the second mortal blade this is huge news as
it's never mentioned that there is a second blade
at all i don't want to overload you with more info
about that blade so we'll talk about it when it's
relevant at the ending but do just remember that
it does exist our journey to the divine dragon
will take us to the mibu village where we're
required to pray in a palaquin before being picked
up by a giant straw doll who transports us to the
fountainhead palace i'll be honest with all of you
i don't got a single explanation for this i don't
know if this is something in japanese culture but
i couldn't find a single thing it's weird and
it's probably better if we just move on and act
like that didn't just happen upon arriving we
encountered the defender of the palace who is
named the corrupted monk her backstory is that
she was among the infested which is why she has
a centipede within her but she doesn't seem to
mind that as she is the palace's guardian after
all so immortality would be quite fitting for
someone like her here in the fountainhead palace
is those carp-like nobles that drink the water
but there's also the okami women sometime long
ago the okami women discovered this palace and
even though the nobles got here first and don't
appreciate visitors they were fine with these
warriors living with them as long as they became
the palace's guardians they agreed and now the
two live together surrounded by the rejuvenating
waters as we talked about earlier tomoe the one
who trained genichiro was originally an okami
woman as she was able to conjure lightning similar
to how they can however this is where things get
a little confusing so tomoe served a lord takeru
think of wolf and kuro's dynamic as the same thing
as theirs takero is kuro and tomoe is wolf just
like our current duo takeru and tomoe were trying
to sever the ties of immortality a majority of her
notes detail their progress on the matter these
notes are actually how wolf and kuro realize that
they needed the mortal blade in order for these
severance to work properly but if we find more of
her notes we can discover more of the story one
of them reads lord takeru's coughs are worsening
still returning to the divine realm is hopeless
and i only wish to sever the dragon's heritage
and restore his humanity so it seemed that the
two wanted to go back to the divine realm implying
that they had been there once before on top of
this information we can also look at the lore
descriptions of the aromatic branch which is on
owl's body in the present and the aromatic flower
which is on his body in the hirata memory from
what i can gather it seems that lord taker was of
the divine lineage since tomoe was trying to sever
his ties of immortality just like we are with kuro
furthermore lord takeru possibly came from the
divine realm which would explain his divine blood
but looking over that note it seems to apply that
tomoe also came from the divine realm but it's
never explained how that's possible once the two
left the divine realm takera would take a branch
from the ever blossom tree as a parting gift and
would eventually plant it into ashina to create
an ever blossom tree we know this because emma
explains that lord takeru used to play the flute
where we're standing while tomoe would dance under
the ever blossom tree however it seems that the
tree withered away despite that being impossible
and it seems it's because owl took a branch from
it possibly because he believed this was required
to obtain immortality so the branch breaking thing
sounds really weird so allow me to elaborate i
believe that takeru took a branch from the ever
blossom tree since it's located in the divine
realm and we know that he lived there once before
he then planted the brand from that tree to make a
smaller ever blossom tree owl then took the branch
from the smaller ever blossom tree and then it of
course withered away so if the branch is able
to destroy a smaller tree what happened to the
big one well we can look at the divine dragon as
the full name of the boss is the divine dragon of
the ever blossom tree when takero snapped a branch
off the ever blossom tree that affected the divine
dragon which is why its arm is missing when we
fight it however even after all their planning it
seems that the duo failed and both died the reason
for their failure is because they didn't have the
mortal blade but we do so we can now succeed where
they failed but we still need those dragon tears
just a reminder in case you forgot we're fighting
this dragon because we need to obtain the divine
dragon tears as it's necessary for the severance
ritual even though there's not much in the arena
itself i really do like this set piece and it's
very gorgeous it's truly divine as the game
intended it for it to be this fight also segways
into another positive about the game and it's
these final death blows, death blows occur when the
player has a full posture bar for bosses there are
multiple death blows that the player must do to
defeat them but when it's the last bar it becomes
a final death blow which is this added part
at the end that ties the whole flight together
i love these death blows a lot, sekiros combat
has always felt stylish to me like it's a dance
the rest of the series has always been about
dodging or blocking the enemy and then when you
succeed do an attack of your own in the beginning
you might be able to get away with this but as
you get deeper many of the fights will have you
moments away from broken posture for a total of 5
whole minutes as if you give the boss any time to
breathe all that momentum is gone sekiro easily
has the most intense combat in the soul series so
it makes sense that you can end your stylish fight
with a stylish finisher you're able to breathe
this sigh of relief knowing that you finally
beat the boss and while doing so are able to watch
this incredible cinematic that caps off the fight
after defeating the divine dragon we cut open
a slit under its eyes to extract its tears and
are now able to start the ritual except we can't
according to emma the central forces have made
it further into the castle and are right outside
the gate in order to avoid death kuro escaped and
went to the secret passage the same one we took
in the intro emma also tells us that lord isshin
has succumbed to his illness and has passed away
honestly before we continue i gotta respect isshin
we never talked about this but after the fight
with gyobu we'll meet with someone named tengu
this person is isshin and judging by the corpse on
the floor he probably killed quite a few ministry
members even at his age he was so strong that
the only thing that could kill him was old age
he's got my respect for that but now we have
entered the finale and while we should go to
kuro we're gonna take a detour and return to the
dilapidated temple as the sculptor is gone halfway
through the game the temple gets covered in these
pieces of paper called ofudas and these papers can
symbolize anything from a medium to allow people
to communicate with deities through prayer or
other things like finding safety or finding love
these papers just like the remnant from earlier in
the video is a hint of what's to come as we run
through the battlefield we'll come across a few
burning structures which isn't out of the ordinary
until we start seeing more and even some claw
marks around them by interacting with the idol we
teleport and find the sculptor who has become the
demon of hatred the sculptor was a shinobi like
wolf who served under isshin and because being a
shinobi means you're surrounded by killing isshin
noticed that shura was going to take over his body
shura is basically when someone kills for the sake
of killing they don't have a reason for doing so
other than the pleasure of taking another life
fearing that the sculptor would succumb to this
fate isshin cut off his arm forcing him to retire
from being a shinobi and temporarily halting shura
the sculptor would also take up wood carving as
we can tell from the buddha statues as a way for
him to keep his mind busy but it wasn't enough as
the flames of hatred were still burning inside him
and it was thanks to this war between the central
forces and oceana that caused him to succumb to
the power but because he was able to withhold
it for so long it was an incomplete version
of shura as a completed version of shura is what
wolf could have been when we meet with owl we're
given the choice of obeying or breaking the iron
code if we obey we join forces with owl however
emma and isshin will attempt to stop us in both of
their fights they mention the word shura and how
it's consuming wolf if we manage to defeat both
emma and isshin then we succeed and owl joins us
again but it's too late shura has already consumed
wolfe so while owl celebrates the victory he gets
stabbed the same way he stabbed wolf he is now a
complete version of shura the sculptor was able to
control his hatred for a long time so that demonic
version was only a partial amount of shura whereas
wolf has no intention of controlling it and it
happened immediately so this is the full version
of it we then get to hear a short narration that
states that a massacre had occurred shortly after
this and thousands of people had died wolf had
completely lost it and this is only the beginning
as he still has the blood of the divine dragon
inside of him so he's still immortal but even if
for some reason he did kill kuro and now doesn't
have the resurrection ability he now has a new
weapon in his arsenal when al returned he came
back with another sword that is the other mortal
blade so wolf is possibly immortal with two mortal
blades and his prosthetic he is never going to die
but how did owl find the second mortal blade well
if we fast forward back to where we left off when
we try to escape with kuro we find genichiro
again who has the black blade in his possession
meaning awol took this from genichiro huge credit
by the way goes to Zullie The Witch for this as i
don't have access to a free cam mode on the xbox
but if you use the free cam mode during the shura
ending you'll notice that the object in owl's hand
when he approaches wolf is genichiro head he
literally killed him took the blade and his head
and then placed it next to his dead grandfather
which is extremely gruesome and definitely in
line with the mood of the shura ending however
if we don't do that ending and instead disobey
the code then that leads to all the events we've
covered so far which brings us back to the flower
garden against genichiro at this point we've faced
genichiro so many times that he isn't that hard
anymore but there's no way and genichiro was going
down without a fight if we managed to kill him
he'll use the power of the black blade and summon
isshin the sword saint there isn't much info on the black
blade but the item description of the black scroll
states the blade's name is open gate and is said
to hold the power to open a gate to the underworld
it is through this power that it creates life this
blade and the mortal blade are opposites to one
another one blade can make the undying die and the
other can revive those who are dead as for the why
i think it's related to the sword saints remnant
which reads one who returns from the great beyond
does so at the peak of their prosperity ishin
coveted strength and all manner of techniques
through his mortal struggle he wished for war
until his final hour and that is precisely what
he got this isn't the same issue that died at the
castle i think of it as a mindless version of him
who just wants to fight going back to its name
open gate that's why genichiro slices his neck
open as it's opening a portal to the underworlds
that isshin may come out and take over genichiro
while he sacrifices his life at this point though
the reveals and constant appearance of genichiro
might be getting annoying and i can totally see
that but i have to disagree him showing up every
time always meant something big was about to
happen and he never disappointed plus it once
again reinforces his personality he is willing to
do anything possible to save ashina he went from
a standard samurai to conjuring lightning to using
the black blade to then fully unleashing its power
by resurrecting isshin if that's not determination
i don't know what is honestly i can't even blame
him for this decision resurrecting isshin was a
smart move as he kicked my ass for two straight
hours it takes everything you have to beat him
and i know many people may want to discuss how
you have to fight him honorably but we have
to remember the way of the ashina
who cares how we beat him as long
as you win that's all that counts genichiro took
this to heart as we can see all the different ways
he's attempted to beat us and even isshin does
this as well as he goes from a sword to a spear to
using lightning to even using a gun at one point
fighting in literally took everything i learned
up until this point to beat him so it's fitting
that after two hours of failure wasting all my
healing on the first phase i managed to beat him
only using two gourds there was only one move in
the last phase that caused me to heal and it was
this lightning attack that i had mistimed besides
that just about everything else in this fight was
flawless and i couldn't have asked for a better
conclusion after isshin is finished we can now
decide our ending and on screen is the items that
correlate with each of them ending 2 only requires
the dragontears this sees us perform the immortal
severance meaning we take the mortal blade kill
kuro and fulfill his wish with no master and no
purpose wolf becomes the new sculptor he's in a
similar situation as the sculptor once was he has
no purpose anymore and has this burning sensation
of killing taking over his body so he attempts to
quell the pain by carving statues we can see that
emma joins us and becomes our permanent doctor and
also gives us our arm back as she says that we
may need to give this to someone in the future
we learn when we get the prosthetic arm that this
originally belonged to the sculptor who passed it
down to wolf who is now going to pass it down
to someone else the souls games have always had
this theme of cycles like the age of fire or even
the hunter's dream if we choose a specific ending
and this seems to be the same in the future some
other person will stumble here with a cut-off arm
and wolf will pass it down to that person and who
knows maybe wolf will become the demon of hatred
like the sculptor and will need to be put down by
that new warrior one thing that is confirmed is
that he no longer has the power of the divine
blood thanks to kuro's death and we know this
because the white streak in his hair has gone
back to its original color for ending 3 we need
the dragon tears and the aromatic flower which we
got from fighting owl in the herata memory this is
the other ending emma and wolf were looking
into that involved wolf sacrificing himself
to make her human again just like how tomoe
wanted to make takeru human again but failed
it's a really sad ending having to see our
protagonists die like that even though it was
a necessary sacrifice it is still heartbreaking to
see we then get to see emma and kuro and it seems
that kuro was leaving ashina and will live his
life as he should now that he is mortal and knows
what it means to be human he wants to live his
life to the fullest while he can our final ending
which many consider to be the true ending of
the game sees us use the divine dragon tears and
the frozen tears which is an item we get from the
divine child of rejuvenation i'll be honest again
i can't explain what we did to get this ending and
i can't imagine someone doing this without a guide
it's like a 15-step process that requires you
to find five different items with no indication
on where they are my personal gripes with that
aside wolf will use the items on kuro and carry
him to the divine child who then for a lack of
a better word consumes him she ends up becoming
a cradle for the divine heir which is something
she talks about during that 15 step process and
it's why we go to her for this ending she along
with wolf then set out to the divine dragon's
birthplace in hopes of sending it back to where it
came just like many of the series secret endings
it's very confusing and doesn't really make a
whole lot of sense as there's little to go off
of but it's possible that through this ritual
the divine dragon now lives inside kuro who is
now inside the divine child and can now be safely
escorted back home i'm not entirely sure if that's
what's going on but i would assume if the dragon
leaves japan then the rejuvenating waters would go
with it returning the land back to normal i have
the same opinion on this as i do the other game's
secret endings and that's while cool i just never
felt any impact from them as they confuse me more
than anything it's hard to appreciate something
that you don't understand so if i had to choose an
ending i'd probably pick the purification ending
that has wolf sacrificing himself it's sad but it
feels complete one thing that puzzles me though
about these endings is the fate of kuro emma and
wolf as we know the central forces were invading
ashina and there's no doubt that they won as not
only do they have the strength weaponry and
numbers it would also undermine the entire
story if they failed which makes this all the more
confusing as you would think that this group would
be hunted down maybe since they're not soldiers
per se they didn't bother fighting them but as we
can see from the destruction that was both caused
at ashina and hirata i don't think they possess
some moral compass so your guess is as good as
mine with the endings finished though we've come
to the end of sekiro and that's something i wish
i didn't have to say just yet as sekiro does not
have any dlc there is the gauntlets of strength
but as for the story related content there is
nothing this is the first time since demon souls
or one of the games didn't have a story dlc and
i find that quite upsetting there is still tons
of story that could have been explained like the
origins of tomoe or even the central forces and it
sucks that we'll most likely never see them again
despite that though sekiro was such a different
experience compared to the past souls games in
both gameplay and story and while things did
get a little bit complicated along the way
as a whole the story was fantastic it's got a
barrier of entry that is low enough to where
you actually understand what you're supposed to
do and why but it's also deep enough for those
that want to know everything about the game it's
able to satisfy both crowds of players and coming
from a series where you're more than likely going
to finish a play through without understanding a
single thing that happened that's very impressive
and definitely deserves some recognition simply
put if you're a fan of the souls games go pick up
sekiro you won't be disappointed
if you made it this far then you made it to the outro and i hope
you enjoyed the video if you did then be sure to
like and subscribe if you're new sekiro was a
blast to play but we're still not done yet we
have a lot more souls content to get through and
i hope that you'll continue to join me on this
journey through the series while you wait for the
next video be sure to check out my story review on
bloodborne as well as any other videos that may
interest you if you haven't seen them as always
thank you to my returning viewers for coming
back and with that take care everyone goodbye